so you know what was it like for you  shooting with Cara this season having  these you know quieter more intimate  moments and I've known her for so many  years it was honestly like working with  a childhood friend we already have that  relationship in terms of like  comfortability so we just enjoyed it  she's hilarious I think she did so great  and she's a great hang yeah really fun I  love that thing Marty just took me it's  like come here I want to get to know you  probably I was like cool I love that  stuff you know there's no small talk we  just went in deep and we're talking  about our favorite condiments we both  love French mustard a lot